very excited my wife and i are
celebrating our first anniversary this
week
thank you
yeah she and i decided to have a
heterosexual wedding uh you have to
discuss everything these days you can't
take any detail for granted i told her i
identify as the groom she's like i feel
like the bride i'm like great that's one
thing down
let's talk appetizers
we had a bit of a love story she and i
uh we reconnected after 10 years
there was an age difference and there
still is
that's how meth works but it feels like
less now because we're both older she is
in her early 30s i'm in my late 40s they
say a woman's sexual prime is her 30s so
she is in her sexual prime
and i
am not
i'm past my prime like do you remember
when shaq played for the celtics
that's me
he didn't look like himself anymore he
had a hard time getting up and down the
court
he was an embarrassment some nights and
i bet there were nights where shaq's
teammates were very angry at him like
shaq what's your problem do you even
want to play with us do you have any
passion for the game
and shaq was probably like no guys i
love you it's just that i'm a little
older now it takes me a little longer to
warm up maybe if you could just be a
little patient
shaq probably said to them
and i just feel it was really wrong of
shaq's teammates to treat him that way
he was a legend he had accomplished a
lot in the game
and sure if shaq would be honest with
himself he would admit that basketball
didn't mean as much to him as it once
did
there was a time when all shaq thought
about was basketball all day
every day but not anymore he was an
older man and in a lot of ways wiser
and if you look back shaq had some
really good games for the celtics not
every game not every game but on certain
nights he looked like the shack of old
and i just wish that his teammates could
have appreciated those nights instead of
harping on the knights that he had
difficulty performing
i feel for shaq is what i'm trying to
say
the older you get and the longer you've
been with someone the sex isn't as
important as making sexual threats
you know what i mean you just have to
throw it out there like someone's gonna
get it tonight no one's gonna get it
it's just a nice thing to say it's a
nice gesture
like you better watch out you're gonna
get punished it's like what's the
punishment we're going to watch a show
and go to bed that's what we do
every night it's not a punishment
when we first moved in together there
was like a kind of an adjustment period
we were fighting it seemed to get better
once i learned to apologize that seemed
to help things immeasurably so i make it
a habit now i say babe i'm sorry please
forgive me
i love you and then she says well you
can't just say i'm sorry it's not just
about saying the words i'm sorry you
have to understand what you did you
can't just say i'm sorry and it's over
and then i say you're right
i'm sorry
please forgive me i apologize
and then she says well it's not like
it's the first time i've ever said this
to you i've said it many times before
you just keep doing the same thing over
and over and over again when are you
gonna get through your head
then i say
what the hell i'm not hitler i'm just a
human being maybe you could cut me some
slack
actually i say i'm sorry please forgive
me
i apologize
but we're finding out obviously more and
more that women have it harder than men
would you say
no no one here thinks that
i've been doing a bit of independent
research
and i think that women do have it i
think women put up with so much crap for
men their entire lives from the time
they're little girls whether it's
coaches
teachers family members neighbors fellow
classmates colleagues bosses random
jerks on the street that by the time
they finally settle on you
it's like they finally got through to
customer service
and you are going to get an earful
because they are not happy with the
product
yeah
oh yeah
they have got some complaints and you
just picked up
you're going to be tempted to say things
like i'm sorry that's not my department
let me transfer you
but it's all your department you're the
only one in the department so just get
used to saying things like i'm sorry
please forgive me i love you and you
have a shot at keeping your job
yes